[Music]
laughs is like a spiritual practice for
me a lot everywhere I go
what I believe that world can be a
better place with more and more people
start laughing my name is madame Kataria
I'm a medical doctor and creator of
laughter yoga this time laughter yoga is
a unique concept where anyone can laugh
for no reason at all we don't need to
rely on jokes sense of humor or comedies
laughter and whines the negative effects
of stress and makes our immune system
stronger and brings more oxygen to our
body and brain the reason we call it
laughter yo guys it's a combination of
laughter exercising with DVD techniques
from yoga scientifically our body
doesn't know the difference between real
laughter and fake laughter we still get
the same health benefits
I created laughter yoga because my life
was very stressful
being editor of a health magazine and
medical practitioners I could not find
any relief from the stress then I found
a breakthrough that there is a lot of
medicine in laughter
based on this idea I created laughs as a
form of exercise I wake up at 4:00 in
the morning and the first thing I do is
allow for 30 40 minutes every day I'm
laughing in my daily routine laughing
with my staff everybody calls me nobody
says I laughing on skype
I'm teaching laughter yoga one day I'm
going to die laughing my mission in life
is to create social after clubs which
are free for everyone in the world when
we laugh in a group it becomes real and
contagious it becomes easier to laugh
now we have more than 16-thousand
laughter clubs in 100 countries when you
find happiness with with laughter
practice the perception of the optimal
we can create happiness within ourselves
[Music]
please put your hands together for
Danielle Perez give it over those strong
gentlemen keep it going for them listen
me on stage I'm gonna hit them up for a
foot massage later when I'm on stage and
I'm performing
I feel really powerful what I'm saying
is being like telegraphed to all these
people that are there to hear my story
and be exposed to you know a Latina
who's disabled and in a wheelchair it's
just a really important thing to be
onstage representing that my name is tal
Perez and I'm a stand-up comedian
performing stand-up comedy while using a
wheelchair is a bit of a challenge first
of all people are always a little
they're just thrown off they don't
really get what's going on I'm really
excited to be here tonight just debuting
my new look which is aggressively fat
yet still very judgy I started comedy
three years ago I realized I love doing
comedy after my first open mic people
laughed at me and that felt so good like
I wanted to hold on to that feeling
forever and I was like I need to do more
of this I'm a big girl but I can tell
that I've gained a little bit of weight
because people keep asking me if I have
diabetes which is really rude because I
was hit by a train I've gone through a
lot of dark things eating disorders
depression
I lost my feet when I was 20 I
definitely use comedy to speak about
those things but also to entertain
and through that find healing and myself
I think that comedy is really helpful
tool in healing and bringing people
together when you see someone on stage
that is sharing a story or telling a
joke and you're like oh I get that I do
that too it unifies and brings people
together and it's a form of catharsis I
go sit on my therapist about two years
ago but realized I should get back into
it when I started daydreaming about
walking into traffic and I don't have
feet I think the message that I want to
put out in the world is that it's okay
to be yourself it's okay to be weird and
different you're only given one
opportunity in this world so make it the
best you can
[Music]
[Music]
challenger from muharram Yamaha Calabria
Jesse unordinary picture 19:14 McGee who
square bar or Adcock concave in to call
him badly
Evita booty Loman much over hand over
glass in the town of a deep or in
India's Gujarat state you will find a
man who is arguably Charlie Chaplin's
biggest fan mera naam tsukumo lost money
on man Charlie Chaplin coke for hot
Bob Barker Tommy Jarvis Africa pehla
pehla movie the Kommandant gold rush or
hunger a bellyful of the artha whose
foster karate bought the picture of
twenty Charlie something with a funny
picture taking Tom on deck physical
hasta the load photo girl ibaka the six
Alicia Gilligan dr. a Swami practices
herbal medicine in his village and uses
Charlie Chaplin to help treat his
patients logically advocating a son DVD
be Charlie Chaplin the account object
their heads of mushrooms
laughter is the best medicine
[Music]
doctoral swanee isn't the only one with
a passion for mr. Chaplin
he started the Charlie Circle in 1973 to
honor and remember one of the world's
greatest comedians Charlie Chaplin is
beloved because of his everyman attitude
and comedy that brought joy to the
masses I'll be Holly Muhammad Ali said
you can juice of the sagina get it
dr. Dubin on a theme song every year the
Charlie Circle celebrates Charlie
Chaplin with a parade singing dancing
and of course cake I want to keep him
alive till I am Alive and then my
grandsons
my friends and all these fellows will
keep them alive because of his more or
less acting without saying in a wash to
the public
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goosebumps is one of the best-selling
book series of all time and this man is
responsible for each and every
terrifying spine-tingling
horror filled story hi I'm RL Stine I
write the Goosebumps books oh maybe he's
not so scary I actually started as a
humor writer well what do you know
in 1992 scholastic released the very
first goosebumps book but way before
that a young Bob Stein was into writing
jokes I started writing funny stuff when
I was 9 years old all I ever wanted to
be was funny when I came to New York I
had my own humor magazine and after ten
years I thought gee I've done what I
always wanted to do I guess I'll Coast
the rest of my life I had no idea what
was in store for me and then things
started to get spooky I had lunch with
the editorial director at scholastic she
had a fight with a why a horror writer
and she said you could write a good why
a horror novel I say okay no problem you
got it and I went home and wrote this
novel and it was a number one bestseller
I thought whoa wait a minute
forget the funny stuff and I've been
scary ever since that book marked the
start of RL Stein's horror writing
career and he eventually wrote an entire
series called goosebumps but it wasn't
an immediate success they went out and
they just sat on the shelves they didn't
sell two months goes by three months
nothing we figured that's it didn't work
out and then something happened it's a
mystery
kids discovered it somehow nobody knew
me really there was no hype no
advertising no publicity there was
nothing just kids telling kids it's just
you know one of these amazing lucky
things that happened now after 25 years
goosebumps is scaring a whole new
generation of kids it's a really nice
thing to be able to write for different
generations at first I was shocked when
adults started showing up at my book
signings I'd say what are you doing here
if we loved you when we were kids and I
realized I'm nostalgia to them I think
you kind of remember that tingle of fear
that you had when you were a kid but
with the success of goosebumps does
arist I never missed the chance to be
funny there's something weird with my
brain because horror always makes me
laugh it's the same disre reaction
that's what I try to do in my books
people think if you're a horror writer
you're scary all the time and your whole
life is horror but I did my own
late-night comedy show at Upright
Citizens Brigade last year I'm waiting
by the phone no one's called me I'm
waiting how is it that might be my
comedy career
[Music]